what's going on patrons this is Rob and
this week you guys cast your votes and
decided that you wanted me to discuss
what would happen if two of the most
powerful entities in the respective
universes went head-to-head as we've hit
the Living Tribunal against the spectre
and so as we do each time with these
videos we're gonna go over each
character in terms of their origin and
abilities and then decide which of these
immensely powerful beings would emerge
victorious
so the Living Tribunal was created by
Stan Lee Marie Severin and herb Trump
and first appeared in 1967 s strange
tales issue number 157 now in his first
appearance The Living Tribunal appeared
to Doctor Strange and informed him that
because he had determined that the earth
had a great potential for evil that he's
simply gonna destroy it which I guess
makes sense because it's just easier
than anything else but fortunately
Doctor Strange convinces the Living
Tribunal to spare the earth by pointing
out that the planet also has potential
for good and that a sorcerer supreme
Stephen strange could be capable of
maintaining the balance between the two
forces of Earth and this first
appearance really strikes to the heart
of the reason for the living tribunals
existence within the Marvel Universe as
an entity that has existed since the
beginning of time and exists as a judge
committed to preserving the balance of
the Marvel multiverse in the event that
a universe becomes unstable the Living
Tribunal judges the universe and enacts
an appropriate punishment which usually
means that he just destroys it The
Living Tribunal is composed of three
aspects equity vengeance and necessity
each of which is represented by one of
his three faces and all of which must be
in agreement in order for him to take
any action now moving on to the living
tribunals powers it's really difficult
to create a list that fully captures
what he's capable of and I feel like I
say this a lot when it comes to these
videos but you guys really like the
ultra powerful characters so I guess
that just kind of comes with the
territory but basically the Living
Tribunal is omniscient and nearly
omnipotent and is considered the second
most powerful being in the Marvel
Universe behind only the one above all
now the little tribunal can manipulate
reality and summon other insanely
powerful cosmic entities like the
in-betweener at will he was also able to
turn the Silver Surfer into a God by
allowing him to touch the void on the
fourth side of his head which is kind of
a weird thing to say but there are four
sides to his head but only three of them
actually have faces so the Silver Surfer
touched the other side and became a god
I hope that makes sense but the Living
Tribunal can also manipulate time being
able to bring time to a standstill
throughout the entire universe
as well as speeding time up to
accelerate the death of a son which
under normal circumstances would take
billions of years now in one of his most
impressive displays of power the Living
Tribunal was able to negate the effects
of the fully assembled Infinity Gauntlet
which is capable of altering the fabric
of reality and pretty much achieving
anything its wielder desires and later
was able to restore the Infinity
Gauntlet to power now when judging
whether the Beyonder should be allowed
to retain his omnipotence within his own
universe the Living Tribunal
contemplates taking the beyonders power
away which suggests that he's capable of
taking away power from other nyama
'putin beings now after deciding that
the Beyonder was allowed to keep his
power he sealed him in a pocket universe
that he could not interfere with other
universes the Living Tribunal is also
capable of replacing one universe with
another as we see when he considers
replacing the main Marvel Universe with
the ultimate universe which he
ultimately decided against and finally
the Living Tribunal was able to absorb
protege a being that had duplicated the
tribunals power and attempted to usurp
the role of the one above all so yeah
the Living Tribunal is a being of nearly
unimaginable power and it's going to
prove to be nearly impossible to defeat
but is the specter up to the challenge
well the specter was created by Jerry
Siegel and nirn art Bailey and made his
debut in more fun Comics number 52 in
1940 now there have been a couple of
versions of the spectres origin but
we're gonna use the most recent of them
for the purpose of this video and so the
spectre is an entity that has existed
since man walked the earth and was once
an angel named a star that sided with
Lucifer during the rebellion against God
but sought forgiveness for his betrayal
now as punishment for his part in the
rebellion he's forced to serve as the
embodiment of God's wrath now eventually
his wrath grows so great that he rejects
the very concept of mercy and from that
point on has to be bonded to human hosts
out of hope that his anger would be
somewhat tempered by their humanity now
there had been multiple hosts of the
spectre but the one that we see most
frequently is a guy by the name of Jim
Corrigan now as for his powers the
spectre is one of the most powerful
entities in the DC Universe and like the
Living Tribunal is nearly omnipotent he
also possesses near omniscience
telekinesis matter in reality
manipulation and can travel through time
the spectre was able to pick up planets
and use them as weapons and by merely
walking caused earthquakes in the
demonic realm he can travel at the speed
of light and dodged a punch thrown by
the flash that was said to be traveling
fast enough to knock a planet off of its
axis the spectre is extremely adept at
using magic and is more proficient than
dr. fate who's widely considered to be
one of the most powerful magicians in DC
Comics the spectre can also manipulate
his size to grow up to the size of an
entire universe and was able to create a
supernova in the palm of his hand even
more impressively the spectres reality
warping is so advanced that he was able
to create a nexus that forged all
realities the spectre has broken the
source wall which separates the DC
Multiverse from the source of all
existence and his battle with the
anti-monitor produced enough energy to
destroy all space and time and ended up
rebooting the entire DC Universe during
crisis on Infinite Earths with all that
in mind we can see that the spectre is
also a being of ridiculous power in his
own right so the question becomes how do
we decide who wins in a battle of two
characters who are both nearly
omnipotent well I think you guys really
love putting me in this situation of
trying to find out a way to decide which
ridiculously powerful character would
beat the other because you guys do it
all the time but in this case I actually
think this one is a pretty easy call
believe it or not as powerful as both of
these guys are I don't really see this
Spectre putting up much of a fight here
now that might sound strange but these
guys are really not operating on the
same level
well yes both the spectre and The Living
Tribunal are able to work reality and
manipulate matter and while both of
these characters are tasked with issuing
judgment from a supreme deity the scales
on which they operate are vastly
different
while the spectre judges souls as the
embodiment of God's wrath The Living
Tribunal judges entire universes and
couldn't wipe them out with merely a
thought when we look at the feeds of
these two characters it's really not up
for debate that the Living Tribunal has
displayed far more power than the
Spector ever has and so I know that
these two characters were presented as
being analogs of one another in the
Marvel vs. DC miniseries in the 90s but
I don't really think that this is an
accurate comparison it's always hard to
put into words why one character is
described as nigh on nip attend and
could defeat another character that's
described the same way but I think the
best way to put this is that if the
Living Tribunal showed up in the DC
Universe I feel like he could wipe out
the entirety of it including the spectre
if he chose to with nothing more than a
wave of his hand but would that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end I love you guys you all are
amazing keep an eye out for the poll for
next week's video and I won't catch
you all later purse
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]